[Música]
cuando alguien me pregunta a qué me
dedico habitualmente mi respuesta es que
me dedico a
hacer lo que otros tal vez no hacen yo
trabajo de escuchar a las personas yo
escucho los directivos de una
organización con la cual me reúno
escucho a la persona que me vende la
fruta la verdura en el mercado escucho a
un político hablando en televisión
yo trabajo de observar de observar a las
personas moverse identifican sus gestos
como en las manos cuáles son sus
emociones es que en realidad mi trabajo
tiene que ver con impulsar empresas a
transformarse yo su ayuda a las
compañías a redefinirse a repensarse
adaptarse y ser exitosos en un mundo en
constante cambio y para hacer eso por
supuesto tengo que entender el mundo en
el que estamos viviendo si no no podría
ayudarlas nunca pero también tengo que
entender e identificar cuáles son las
señales que sean en el presente que
representan potenciales futuros
plausibles coherentes provocativos
porque así así suelen transformarse las
empresas en mi afán de escuchar hace un
poquito menos de dos años todavía vivía
en argentina caminando con las calles de
madrid me topé con carlos carlos una
persona de alta pelo bastante cortito
barba tupida carlos vivía en la calle y
cuando me acerco su primera reacción fue
alejarse pero después de dos o tres
bromas empezamos a conversar y se tornó
un día lo super interesante para ambos
pero por lo menos para mí lo fue
y una de las cosas que me contó carlos
fue que
él era dueño y director de una empresa
familiar de una pyme y que la crisis del
2008 lo había llevado a ese lugar eso me
dijo la crisis me llevó a ese lugar a
los pocos días volvió argentina y en las
semanas al poco tiempo
empezamos a escuchar una palabra que
antes sonaba raro hoy es parte de
nuestro vocabulario que es kobe 19
y es así que no era una crisis que sólo
afectaría a carlos ni sólo afectaría a
españa crean medio en argentina tengo un
doctorado en crisis
era evidente quiero hacer una crisis que
nació afectará a todos y con las
empresas que trabajábamos en aquel
momento empezamos a notar que se
empezaron a comportar raro distinto
identifique alguno de los
comportamientos de esas compañías esas
empresas de sus organizaciones eran muy
similares a lo que es carlos me había
contado así es que tomamos un modelo que
teníamos lo que definimos lo
reinventamos lo llenamos de información
y lo llamamos crisis mindset o
mentalidad de crisis y lo hicimos
público porque creímos que así debía ser
este modelo representa aquellas
organizaciones que logran ser exitosas
atravesando una crisis que les va bien
que logran transformarse incluso pero
también representa que sus
organizaciones que sufren y hasta
algunas perecen en el camino
este modelo tiene cuatro pilares
principales y tres
transversales
cada pilar tiene una polaridad positiva
y una polaridad negativa la polaridad
positiva es la que permite la campana la
que posibilita la que habla alternativa
es la que abre opciones la polaridad
negativa es aquella que limita que
impide que pone barreras que no nos deja
ver más allá y les voy a contar de qué
se trata el primero que llevan en
pantalla
de los pilares es el que llamamos
orientación a la oportunidad o esclavo
de la coyuntura y esto tiene que ver con
el contexto el contexto para todos es un
dato la pregunta es qué hago con ese
dato porque aquellas empresas que están
en la polaridad negativa lo que hacen es
aferrarse a esa única estrategia que no
controlan y que la crisis termine ponen
su su posibilidad de éxito o su fracaso
en algo que no controlan está fuera que
la pandemia se termine que la regulación
desaparezca que se promueve una ley que
el precio de un commodity baje no
control no puede ser mi única estrategia
eso es ser esclavo de la coyuntura
espero que pase las que están en el otro
extremo también desean que pase la
crisis por supuesto pero no es la única
estrategia empiezan a generar algunas
estrategias que complementan empiezan a
buscar oportunidades donde antes no las
tenían porque cuando cambia el contexto
con una crisis empiezan a pasar dos
cosas la primera es que no cambia solo
para mí cambio para todos incluso para
mis clientes para mis consumidores si yo
puedo detectar qué cambio en el otro por
qué lo escucho porque lo observo
entonces
sin necesidades que otros no detectaran
y por ende puedo hacer algo al respecto
eso genera alternativas y opciones el
segundo que sucede con un cambio de
contexto es que las reglas de juego
cambian lo que antes no se podía o no se
permitía ahora empieza a poder sea
permitirse porque tengo nuevas
herramientas que puedes explotar puedes
llegar a nuevos resultados y esa
combinación de nueva necesidad con nueva
regla de juego
abre un mundo de oportunidades que me
permiten empezar a aprovechar esto
el segundo de los pilares
es el que llamamos
movimiento continuo
y el nombre de parálisis por análisis
parálisis y movimientos opuestos
aquellas organizaciones que están en el
extremo limitante que se paralizan
la van a tener poco más complicada todos
nos paralizamos cuando hay una crisis es
imposible no hacerlo la pregunta es
cuánto tiempo permanece mos en ese
estadio
cuando nos paralizamos a mí me gusta
graficar lo como esto agarramos una
planilla de cálculo habitualmente excel
y empezamos a ver números y celdas y
fórmulas y guardar tratando de que los
números den cuando esa planilla de
cálculo fue creada antes de la crisis
nunca va a funcionar durante una crisis
no funciona en este contexto no tratemos
de enfocarnos en eso y nos volvamos
obsesivos porque ahí no está la solución
nunca la vamos a encontrar vamos a
paralizar nuestras donde analizar cómo
salir ya que hay ahí no está la solución
la solución está en el otro extremo en
el moverme rápido
tengo que empezar a pensar en dejar los
pilares sobre los cuales nuestras
compañías siempre son fueron construidas
la robustez la previsibilidad la
escalabilidad no me sirve para nada en
este momento que es peor que ser
previsible hoy en día esto que pensar a
pensar nuevos pilares la agilidad la
flexibilidad la versatilidad antes
hablaban de bruce lee y el agua algo por
el estilo
porque en ese movimiento continuo si
detecta una oportunidad antes no tengo
que esperar a generar el producto o el
servicio que me va a salvar el producto
perfecto no existe eso tengo que ir
tirando llegando al cliente lo más
rápido posible escuchando analizando lo
que escuche y accionando y empezar a
generar esos productos mínimos viables
que empiezan a satisfacer una necesidad
que ni el otro lado saben que la tienen
esa velocidad para moverme me va a
permitir mantenerme vivo porque el mundo
funciona esa velocidad lo que hace la
crisis es obligarme a funcionar cómo
funciona el mundo
por ende algunas crisis estas son
positivas porque lo peor que puede hacer
es quedarme con el status quo en
quedarme con las recetas que traigo del
pasado porque el status quo no existe es
un invento del ser humano para estar más
tranquilo para tener menos incertidumbre
en el status quo casi todos los días
el tercero
de los pilares es el que llamamos
learning agility o fix learning
básicamente agilidad para aprender o
aprendizaje fijo en el primero en el
limitante el que el aprendizaje fijo me
quedo con las recetas que les conté
antes y que con las habilidades que
tenía antes de la crisis me quedo con
las herramientas que supe usar en un
contexto que ya no tiene sentido es como
jugada de baloncesto con guantes de
educción las manos en esta situación en
esta regla de juego no necesito esas
herramientas tengo que desarrollar
juntas herramientas otras habilidades
que antes no necesitaba por ende nunca
las desarrolle bueno estamos en el kauno
para desarrollarlo porque no podemos
esperar que la crisis termine para
hacerlo tenemos que ser mucho más ágiles
tenemos que desaprender y re aprender lo
que no me servía lo dejo costado y
empiezo aprender otra cosa
y el foco está puesto en esas
habilidades más técnicas las aprendo
rápido un curso online y lo resolví esta
apuesta de las habilidades que nos da la
vida y las experiencias
empatía pensamiento crítico creatividad
colaboración
liderazgo
de hecho si voy a experimentar como
dijimos antes y darle al cliente algo
que no es perfecto tengo estar dispuesto
a equivocarme porque experimentar
implica ser algo que nunca hice antes es
obvio que me voy a equivocar tengo que
estar dispuesto a eso lo que tiene que
pasar es que tengo que tener la
capacidad aprender de lo que me
equivoque porque lo peor que me puede
pasar es no experimentar por mí
equivocarme y por ende no voy a aprender
y si no aprendo me voy me vuelvo una
organización estúpida
no me queda mucho futuro lo único que es
la crisis es acelera el proceso que iba
a terminar así de una u otra forma
ese es el tercer pilar
el cuarto
me di cuenta que cuando para atrás
funciona mucho mejor
es en la resiliencia o el de crisis
existencial
cuando la crisis empieza a penetrar en
nuestra organización lo que empezamos a
ver son directores de compañías dueños
de empresas familiares que después de
los cinco días que pasa la crisis
empiezan a decir no debería despedir al
20% de mis empleados
y tal vez sí pero seguro está pensando
con la cabeza un poco caliente porque no
enfriamos entendemos qué pasa somos
resilientes entendemos que esto es una
piedra en el camino que podemos esquivar
la eludir la resolver la otra forma no
solo tengo que ser resiliente estamos al
gestionar las emociones porque lo que lo
peor que puede hacer es tratar de
resolver el corto
hipoteca hipotecando el largo porque
aquellas personas que se queden en la
organización que no desespere para
cuestionar
mis acciones porque en estos momentos de
crisis las emociones están muy a flor de
piel
están todos sensibles lo bueno se vuelve
muy bueno lo malo se vuelve muy malo
quiénes trabajan las organizaciones
tienen miedo son los que más miedo
tienen a perder su empleo incertidumbre
vulnerabilidad
entonces de alguna forma tengo que estar
lo más cerca posible es el momento para
gestionar las emociones mejor que nunca
estos son los cuatro pilares principales
de este modelo podría hablarles horas de
esto pero solo tengo 18 minutos así que
voy a pasar a los 3 preconceptos que son
súper importantes para que estos pilares
tengan sentido son preconceptos
preconceptos muy fáciles de entender un
poco más difíciles de aplicar sobre todo
el primero porque bastante antinatural
el primero de ellos
es aquel que dice sin espacio para ellos
no es momento ni de nombres ni de
individualidades nadie nos va a salvar a
esta crisis no va a venir el héroe que
lo va a resolver esto se resuelve
olvidándonos del cape y del área del
indicador de la dirección del bono de
fin de año que tanto es pero esto se
resuelve con un propósito muy claro con
un norte muy claro que permita romper
con los silos
que tienen las organizaciones porque de
esto se sale en equipo construyendo
colectivamente
de esto se sale con arias trabajando en
conjunto por un norte común
el segundo de los preconceptos
los llamamos si le ve el compacto y esto
tiene que ver con habitualmente una alta
dirección o los únicos una compañía como
decíamos recién que habitualmente opinan
muy distinto y está muy bien que eso
pase no hay mejor cosa que en un en alta
dirección tener riqueza de opiniones
pero en estos momentos tienen que
ponerse de acuerdo y más rápido que
nunca
porque cuando piensan distinto se ponen
de acuerdo y el norte está claro el
hacia dónde vamos importa que nos
tomamos eran sinuosos pero en un momento
llegaremos si el norte se mueve
constantemente
difícilmente vamos a llegar
entonces tenemos que empezar a hacer
coherentes cada un las personas que
forman parte de ese liderazgo tienen que
ser coherentes entre sí y no sólo esos
tienen que conocer coherentes cada uno
de ellos individualmente entre lo que
dice y lo que hace porque lo peor que
puedo hacer es decir algo y actuar de
forma contraria porque estoy perdiendo
la transparencia y sí pero la
transparencia pierdo la confianza y si
pierdo la confianza ya nadie me va a
seguir en el momento que más necesito
que me sigan
la confianza se vuelve clave en estos
procesos porque como decíamos antes las
personas sienten incertidumbre lo que
van a hacer primero es mirar para arriba
los líderes si fuese una pirámide
organizacional para entender hacia dónde
ir que tienen que hacer
y aunque es una mala noticia lo mejor
que me puede pasar es que seas
transparente la gente lo va a valorar
el último de estos preconceptos es el
que llamamos sincronicidad ya que me
gusta graficar lo como los equipos de
remo vieron que todos van a uno es
increíble uno lo ve por televisión no sé
si alguna practica el deporte van todos
a la misma velocidad al mismo ritmo con
la misma dirección de la misma
frecuencia y si uno de ellos no lo hace
igual que el resto la meta empieza están
mucho más lejos así tiene que funcionar
una organización en un momento en el
cual está atravesando una crisis y tiene
que hacerlo de esta forma para que cada
una de las personas sepa cuál es su rol
y qué tiene que hacer para cumplir con
ese propósito vieron como los vikingos
que van con los tambores y todos saben
que cuando va a determinado ritmo del
tambor todos van a la guerra y cuando se
desacelera hacemos unos pasos para atrás
así funciona la sincronización en una
organización porque puedes tener
proyectos espectaculares que no van a
sacar nos van a sacar de la crisis pero
si no se hablan entre sí si no están
sincronizados van a ser otras acciones
espasmódicas son espasmos con muy buena
intención pero poco elimina miento con
lo cual se hace el mismo esfuerzo pero
se avanza muy poco
este es el modelo
y más allá de las dos polaridades que
les conté hay algo que es clave es el
foco que tienen las organizaciones y las
personas que trabajan en ella
porque las organizaciones que son
exitosas atravesando una crisis se
olvidan por un rato de lo que falta para
poner el foco en lo que está disponible
se olvidan por un rato de las cuentas
para poner el foco en el agregado de
valor
se olvidan por un rato de lo que fueron
para potencialmente concentrar antes de
concentrarse lo que pueden ser lo peor
que me puede pasarse para que la crisis
termine para volver a ser lo que era
cuando el radio tengo la oportunidad es
algo mucho mejor que lo que era
me gustaría volver a caminar por madrid
y encontrarán con carlos y decirle que
esto fue inspirado en su historia y me
gustaría decirle también que lo que está
viviendo en este momento es una crisis
pero que tiene la oportunidad de que
termine como él le gustaría que termine
con el mainz et indicado muchas gracias
[Aplausos]